good morning everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be studying today is SCP $31.99
object class Keter special containment
procedures all life instances of
scp-1307 our containment chamber the
walls of which should be coated and
approximately two centimeters thick acid
resistance steel two meters of empty
space are to be allocated between this
chamber and secondary containment
secondary containment consists of
suspending all live instances of
scp-1307 transparent substance currently
clear acrylic resin the block is to be
at a height of at least three meters
with one arm security guards stationed
directly outside initial containment at
all times an eight digit passcode can be
obtained from the current site 114
director in order to access the initial
containment chamber and allow for up
close examination of SCP $31.99 s
behavior and appearance
CCTV equipment is however installed in
one corner of the containment cell for
remote observation secondary containment
is to be regularly examined for damages
any sign of aggressive activity will be
noted and the current site 114 director
informed at the earliest possible
convenience a temporary recall procedure
is detailed in addendum $31.99 three
experiments involving the use of live
SCP $31.99 instances are strictly
prohibited without approval from at
least two personnel of level 4 security
clearance or above as of December 6th
there are four present and contained
instances of
description SCP $31.99 is a sentient
humanoid species of a currently unknown
biological origin though tissue samples
suggests traces of domestic chicken and
chimpanzee DNA instances of scp-1307
layer of albumin and stand at an average
of 2.9 meters weight averages from 780
kilograms for a matured instance and 360
kilograms for a hatchling the necks of
SCP $31.99 appear dislocated and are
capable of twisting approximately 340
degrees presumably due to the nature of
SCP $31.99 s reproductive cycle SCP
$31.99 are opportunistic hunters
engaging with live subjects within a
currently unidentified radius has been
stricken from the document within a
radius of 0.9 kilometers surrounding
hatchlings that have not yet reached
full adolescence average speed is
recorded at 25 km/h upon contact with
human or animal subjects SCP $31.99 will
proceed liquefying internal organs and
bone structure the cadaver is then
transported to the young and utilized as
a form of nourishment instances of
scp-1305 coloration and rubbery
appearance these eggs pass through the
entity's stomach esophagus and
eventually out via the mouth followed by
a red viscous substance first thought to
be a form of placenta chemical breakdown
has determined it to be a highly
corrosive material SCP $31.99 shows
extreme distress throughout the process
with personnel describing the sound as
not dissimilar to a scream presumably
due to a biological ingrained method of
avoiding extinction SCP $31.99 produces
its eggs to fill available space the
anomalous property currently has no
known limit
and as a result may pose an elk a class
species transmutation scenario
termination of SCP $31.99 can be
performed with relative ease however a
complete eradication is currently
impossible which has been stricken from
the document difficult as all instances
of scp-1307
carry one egg inside their stomach
ensuring survival for at least one
member of their species at all times
examples have proven to be extremely
resilient lacking visible signs of
damage after subjection to extreme
blunt-force trama extensive pressure
exceeding 180,000 PSI high-precision
blades serrated and non serrated and
finally long term acid exposure use of
point-blank explosives was suggested but
never tested heat exposure has been
determined to accelerate hatch rates and
thus detonation may run the risk of a
containment breach see addendum $31.99
for SCP $31.99 was issued Keter
classification on October 6 2017
following the events of a containment
breach
SCP $31.99 s original water containment
method was disassembled and replaced
with the current resin solution
addendum $31.99 120 1705 dispatched the
following notice regarding SCP $31.99
all experiments involving a CP $31.99
egg samples are strictly prohibited
until further notice hatching periods
have proven too unreliable to warrant
extensive research and as the
consequences of a containment breach
become more and more apparent the o-5
Council have collectively decided to
eliminate risks of the source and
prevent testing until new information
surfaces we thank you for your
cooperation
SCP $31.99 was discovered in ireland
after reports of an unidentified bald
creature crying like a banshee from
within a dense woodlands resulted in the
dispatching of mole task force omega 19
onlet to personnel were lost in action
their internal organs and John's having
been almost entirely dissolved during
transportation SCP $31.99 produced two
offspring resulting in the deaths of a
further six personnel and the following
is stricken from the document it is
entirely unknown as to how the first
instance of scp-1337 - addendum $31.99 -
2017 a thorough sweep of SCP $31.99 s
initial recovery location was performed
in an attempt to uncover any further
information regarding their origin
locals claimed that the small remote
residence in question has been
established in the woods for several
years surface team D 29 recovered
several items of interest including one
bag of assorted thread and needles of
various colors and sizes approximately
13 chicken carcasses based on the
collective halves and quarters with
precise incisions located on the
underbelly neck and thigh six of the
carcasses had been plucked with visible
human teeth marks lining the bare areas
seemingly at random several containers
including water bottles and Tupperware
boxes holding an unidentified water tea
paste the paste is deep brown in color
and the presence of oxygen becomes
viscous and hard substance is currently
awaiting chemical breakdown
an a5 notebook brand and heavily
scratched with what was determined to be
human fingernails the words open when we
are pure are written on the front and
finally to chicken feather quilts the
notebook itself consisted of 24 pages of
standard lined paper written in
non-anomalous black ink 19 of these
pages consisted of various cuboid
patterns and crude childlike
illustrations vaguely resembling SCP
$31.99 on the remaining five pages large
lines of writing detailed the diary of
an unnamed individual most of what was
written was found totally illegible
however one extract in particular david
the sixth 1973 was written with notably
higher clarity if you're reading this
then lucky you one millionth hour from
naught and it'll be fun fun and the
wonderful versa
Tilly that VESA versatility of inferior
human DNA will give birth to a new era a
stronger ear one where and food and
water will be nothing but things of the
past as we will make and make and make
more until for the better future
I really haven't much Tim time that's
why I envy you so you'll have all the
time you need time will be a thing of
the time we'll be on and on and death
will be life life new life changes lives
and bring smiles like a freshness new
life will be a part of life from now on
yeah that was kind of tough to read
the final page consisted of several ink
blots 13 instances of the word life in
various sizes and two instances of the
words didn't you want this addendum
$31.99 3 protocol 34 20 to be poached
regarding the rican tainment of SCP
$31.99 the following procedure will
occur in the event of a preach on-site
personnel with level 1 security
clearance are above assumes standard
lockdown procedure and immediately moved
to site 113 unless instructed otherwise
site 114 is to be filled entirely with
distilled water treated with Class A
sedatives surface team tango 306 a will
be notifying and dispatched and
instructed to retrieve any instances of
scp-1307 instances of scp-1307 sported
to a temporary off-site containment and
finally site 114 will then be drained
and janitorial staff dispatched to
thoroughly clean the area personnel
attempting to breach one site 14 before
this inspection is complete will be
apprehended and suspended accordingly
note some personnel have displayed
skepticism regarding the necessity of
SCP $31.99 s current breach protocol to
elaborate we have reason to believe that
fluid is an excellent counter to SCP
$31.99 anomalous reproductive properties
it appears to enter an inert state in
the presence of liquid regardless of
thickness or clarity
there are two theories regarding this
occurrence number one SCP $31.99 s need
for survival demands all of its
attention to focus on not drowning it's
possible we have found a loophole
within its own nature number 2 SCP
$31.99 considers the liquid around it as
full space and as a result does not
produce any young when submerged the
latter theory holds more water as SCP
$31.99 appears to be totally inactive
when submerged for now I believe I speak
for all of site 114 when I say it's a
relief to at least have a consistent
method of containment
dr. wat December 5th 2017
this is video log interview $31.99 one
interviewer dr. Ewing interviewed Lance
Corporal Duncan leading captain of
mobile task force Omega 19 first to
capture and detain a CP $31.99 during
initial recovery forward subject had
undergone extensive psychiatric therapy
prior to interview and whilst not
considered responsible for the deaths of
private McLeod and corporal langley
admitted to having not performed the
necessary precautions playing log now
take you see
[Music]
the job is pretty simple
no auditory or visual triggers at the
eggheads inside 114 knew about seems to
me as if they've done a pretty top job
scraping the area clean never is that
easy though we landed around 2100 hours
the boys and I had been told it a
couldn't catch the thing the next best
thing would be snapping a framework - so
they hooked us up with the best in night
vision hardware I know you have pictures
hello
I know you've got salt you're under no
obligation to view the recording I know
that just show me a little please no we
found something within the hour almost
like a Shack totally out of scrap metal
of would look more like an oversized
chicken coop than anything else but I
don't know that your new Monster built
it just made it a home and as you enter
as soon as possible of course it was a
late shift what that this over as quick
as possible I'd like to say that's why I
did it I can't bring myself to make
excuses
I really [ __ ] it now
pardon my french it's perfectly
appropriate all things considered
however I'm going to have to ask you to
continue explaining the procedure right
right well I had to my men's stations at
the back
private McLeod and Captain Langley
insisted they take first charge fresh
out of training we were kids I should be
used to it now but never seen a smile
could cut it down so quick it knew we
were there somehow jump right at private
McLeod and the [ __ ] teeth out of his
head I see it whenever I blink now
that's the [ __ ] that stays with you I
assure you the foundation will make
every measure to ensure financial
comfort for the families of your last
met could you elaborate on the other
cavity
[Music]
Dokka please I have to urge you to
continue the more we know the more we
can do to stop it from happening again
we barely have time to react before it
start neck and and down the corridor to
the right I guess
the adrenaline and just about head me
because I fired off an off rounds to
blow a chunk out of its chest just as
its ugly head was about to hit a corner
I saw I saw straight [ __ ] moonlight
on the other side
bull's eye then you let out with the
most awful scream I have a beautiful
little baby boy in a home you know for
this procedure
could you place a beautiful baby boy
which is loves Suellen when he's too
cranky to sleep and you know what every
time he does I think about that scream
see pop it into my head think what it
did and his pop gives him a look as if
he's gonna bash his [ __ ] head against
the wall please kill that monster if for
no one else from me and this log has a
note from dr. Ewing which reads I wish
the very best to the families of those
lost during SCP $31.99 s initial
recovery furthermore I would like to
formally request that Lance Corporal
Duncan is administered one Class B
amnestic at the earliest possible
convenience no excuses dr. Lee Ewing
site 114 director
addendum $31.99 for experiment locks
experiment $31.99 a intense heat
exposure subject one example from SCP
$31.99 method subject relocated to a
secure containment cell inside
temperature of the cell was gradually
increased at an average rate of seven
degrees celsius per minute results after
approximately nine minutes the egg
ruptured violently and produced a single
hatchling on site personnel reacted
swiftly to Rican tain the newborn
instance however the excessive internal
temperature impacted the physical growth
of the young instance and it reached
adolescence at an accelerated rate of 40
seconds as a result the now adolescent
hatchling produced to further instances
of scp-1000 I on-site security response
was Swift
and all three instances were detained
all future heat testing involving SCP
$31.99 egg samples has been forbidden
until further notice experiment $31.99 B
liquid nitrogen bath subject one example
from SCP $31.99 method subjects have
merged entirely in liquid nitrogen
security remain on standby throughout
the procedure after concerns regarding
another unexpected outbreak after
approximately 45 minutes of exposure SCP
$31.99 had reached minus 190 degrees
following two hours of exposure the
example was removed and placed under
extreme pressure results hydraulic press
peaked at pressures of around nine
thousand psi cracks appeared 30 minutes
into exposure before the sample
shattered
egg fragments were collected and
furthermore pressed into a fine pulp
zero traces of albumin or yolk were
located incineration of these remains
proved successful at destroying the egg
in its entirety PostScript as dr. Ewing
once put so eloquently let us not allow
these small victories to distract from
the larger picture and whilst you may
find the time to celebrate this
discovery we will not excuse apathy
towards the entity itself
dr. Watt experiment 31 see chemical
analysis of shell sample 10 grams of
finely pressed eggshell pulp taken from
an SCP $31.99 egg results detailed
chemical breakdown shows traces of knock
rrah enamel and a currently unidentified
carbon compound microscope analysis
suggests that the shell itself is
composed of tightly packed organized
crystals practical use of this material
is currently undergoing consideration
all right that about does it for today
thank you all for listening and you are
all dismissed
goodbye I would like to give a special
thank you to Andre Bessette Desmond
Hoskins and gets a berry thank you all
very much for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you
[Music]